there's such a branded look and feel of
jackass too that's like obviously very
authentic it's not like something you
guys sat down and wrote down but i've
always been curious actually there's
like a i edit steve's videos so like i'm
you know
like when did the you know you guys say
a thing blah blah yeah good and then
everyone walks off camera and the like
the walk-off camera after you've like
said your funny thing is kind of like
jackass branded
thing i don't know that always happens
but there's definitely like if you get
the sense that you've just put a button
on something you're walking we have the
instinct to get out of frame yeah like
did that i don't know when did that
start or did you have any well all i
know is like
when i did the self-defense equipment
article for the video i introduced
myself i'm giant knoxville united states
of america and i introduced what i was
going to do in the bit and
when we did the tv show spike said you
should introduce yourself every time he
really liked it i'm like all right
girls spike knows better than me for
sure that man is so great so that's what
started like hi i'm stevo this is the
butt chugger yes because spike's idea
really even though the first time um
the first thing i did that for was the
goldfish and i couldn't do it so
knoxville said hi i'm johnny knoxville
and this is stevo and he's going to do
the goldfish trick because you're
nervous on camera i was so nervous i was
useless on camera for the longest time
now we can't get him to shut up
yeah dude